WAI CHEE DIMOCK: So we're just
going to move on
now and follow up on what we
talked about last time, which is
the sevenfold permutation.
It sounds kind of
intimidating.
But it's actually what we'll be
talking about in the four
classes devoted to For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
And last time we talked a lot
about voluntary versus
involuntary association,
including the idea of the
involuntary foreigners, that
both Americans and the Spanish
actually can be involuntary
foreigners.
The Americans in the simple
fact that they don't have
perfect command of the language,
and also that they
are recognizable as foreigners,
as outsiders in
their community.
But the Spanish can also be
outsiders in their own
community because of two things,
Because of the print
illiteracy, and because of the
technological illiteracy.
So in those two ways they are
both stuck with a kind of
involuntary association.
Today we'll move on to the
next way to configure the
contents of For Whom
the Bell Tolls.
And I'D like to think of it as
a very sustained structure.
Hemingway is a writer who
actually not only starts out
with a pattern, but keeps
elaborating on that pattern.
So in many ways, it really is a
kind of a musical structure,
theme and variation.
And the paradigm of distant
home versus on-site
environment, that actually is
a theme and variation almost
throughout the entire For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
And plugged into that is a kind
of play between the comic
and the tragic.
But really the main, the
dominant theme today, would be
the relation between distant
homes and on-site environment.
So I've seven candidates
for distant homes.
One is in Paris, which is very
odd, because already we're in
a foreign countries, to American
readers, Spain.
But there's yet another foreign
country, France and
especially Paris, which makes
a cameo appearance.
And then there are five
locations, both spatial
locations and temporal locations
in the United States
that are the distant homes
for Robert Jordan.
So we'll talk about why each of
them is involved, and the
relation between that
distant home and the
immediate Spanish setting.
But first of all, Paris.
Paris comes up in the context
of Robert drinking the
absinthe that he carries
with him.
And right before that, he has
actually asked for wine and
there's not a lot
of wine left.
So Maria want to give him wine,
but Pablo says there's
not much left.
So he doesn't get to have the
wine from the locals.
And instead he pulls out this
bottle of absinthe.
And nobody there has seen this,
so he tells us them that
this is medicine.
And the gypsy wants
to taste what this
medicine tastes like.
"Robert Jordan pushed
the cup toward him.
It was a milky yellow now with
the water and he hoped the
gypsy would not take more
than a swallow.
There was very little of it left
and one cup of it took
the place of the evening
papers, of all the old
evenings in cafes, of all the
chestnut trees that would be
in bloom now in this month, of
the great slow horses of the
outer boulevards, of bookshops,
of kiosks, and of
galleries, of the Parc
Montsouris, of the Stade
Buffalo, of the Butte Chaumont,
of the Guarantee
Trust Company and the Il de la
Cite, of Foyot's old hotel,
and of being able to read and
relax in the evening; of all
the things he had enjoyed and
forgotten and that came back
to him when he tasted
that opaque, bitter,
tongue-numbing, brain-warming,
stomach-warming, idea changing
liquid alchemy."
This is as beautiful a praise
song to Paris as I've seen.
But what is odd about this
praise song of Paris is that
it actually is not pointing to
all the monumental tourist
attractions of Paris, no Eiffel
Tower in there, no Arc
de Triomphe.
Instead it is the
chestnut trees--
actually they're horse chestnuts
in this picture.
But chestnut trees, all over
Paris, very common sight.
Kiosks, very, very
common site.
Parc Montsouris is actually kind
of out of the way, and
it's not very spectacular.
it's just a park.
And then this Stade Buffalo,
actually I've never--
I have to look it up, it might
not even be there.
It's a cycling track.
And then the Parc des Buttes
Chaumont, it's also not--
I mean it's a nice park, but I
don't think it's that famous.
It's more of a kind of
a neighborhood park.
It's on a hill.
So there's kind of this
hilly structure.
This is the butte that gives
the park the name.
And the Ile de la Cite
is the island in the
middle of the Seine.
It's a very beautiful place.
But once again, it is a
neighborhood, rather than a
kind of major tourist
attraction.
Although the Notre Dame
cathedral is there.
And finally, the Hotel Foyot,
once again, it's a legend.
But it's also a place that you
would just walk by every day
without noticing it.
And that's really the
main point, is that
all those names --
I don't even think it is
Hemingway name-dropping
because those names
actually are not
recognizable to most of us.
Those are just the neighborhood
features, the
local features, of various
Paris neighborhoods.
And those are the things that
people would walk by every day
and just take them
for granted.
And that is really what Paris
means for Hemingway.
He did spend--
well, for Hemingway and also
for Robert Jordan--
Hemingway did spend several
years in Paris.
He wrote about it in
A Moveable Feast.
And he wrote very
well in Paris.
He said that he could actually
write about Michigan best when
he was in Paris.
He said that in A Moveable
Feast. So it was Hemingway's
home in a sense that it's
a place where a
writer could write.
And I think that there
really is no better
definition of home.
Home is a place where
you can work without
self-consciousness, where
you have a work routine.
And you can count on being
able to produce
something every day.
For me, that's also actually
my own definition of home.
So it's kind of a minor
variation on Hemingway's kind
of total obsession
with writing.
You don't have to
think about it.
It's just there every day,
and you can just do the
same thing every day.
So that is the security and
the everyday-ness of Paris
that is contrasted with the
on-site environment, which is
very violent and unpredictable
where he's
so obviously a foreigner.
Even though Hemingway was a
foreigner in Paris, the fact
that he was able to write
so well in Paris
meant that that actually--
the foreignness was sort of
bracketed by his very
productive relation
to his own craft.
Here in Spain, it's a totally
different relation.
So we'll look at what comes
after that invocation in his
own mind of Paris that is
brought on by the absinthe.
"The gypsy made a face and
handed the cup back.
'It smells of anis but it is
bitter as gall,' he said.
'It is better to be sick than
have that medicine.' 'That's
the wormwood,' Robert Jordan
told them. 'In this, the real
absinthe, there is wormwood.
It's supposed to rot your
brain out but I
don't believe it.
It only changes the ideas.
You should pour water into
it very slowly, a few
drops at the time.
But I poured it into the water.'
'What are you saying?'
Pablo said angrily, feeling
the mockery.
'Explaining the medicine,'
Robert Jordan
told him and grinned.
'I bought it in Madrid.
It was the last bottle and it's
lasted me three weeks.'
He took a big swallow of it and
felt it coasting over his
tongue in delicate anesthesia.
He looked at Pablo and
grinned again."
So we've seen how aggressive
the locals can be when it
comes to hopping on Kashkin.
And there's a foreigner just
like Robert, rare name, dead,
who works the explosives.
The questions from the locals is
very well matched by what I
would say is sort of the
good-natured aggression, but
nonetheless aggression on
the part of Robert.
These people know nothing
about Paris.
They've never been
outside of Spain.
They've never been outside
of the local community.
So it seems that some of them,
many of them, have never been
to Madrid even because these
are the local guerrillas.
They are very much--
they stay put in their
own small community.
So even Madrid is in many ways
a foreign country to them.
And Robert Jordan, the American,
knows Paris, he
knows the capital of Spain, he
knows this liquor that they've
never tasted.
And he's fooling them into
thinking that it's medicine.
And he's drunk the last bottle
of absinthe in Madrid.
So a lot of this, just like the
print illiteracy that he
comes upon, that he just
discovers without meaning to,
this is his actively
highlighting the fact that he
is much more a man of the
world than they are, and
there's no competition.
This is a very well traveled man
just by the nature of what
he's doing, he's
well traveled.
And these people are completely
rooted in their own
environment.
Although I should say that it
is an entirely open question
by the end of the novel, which
is the better fate?
Whether it's the well traveled
person who has a better
future, or whether it's actually
people who are rooted
in their environments who
have a better future.
I think it's very much
an open question by
the end of the novel.
At this moment though, this is
the moment when Robert has his
little victory over
the locals.
He's just able to show them
all the things --
highlight, dramatize to them
-- all the things that he
knows that they don't know.
So the first invocation of a
distant home has the effect
actually of bringing out an
edge to say the least. And
Pablo certainly recognizes
that --
an edge, a tension between
Robert and the locals who are
otherwise his comrades.
They're on the same
side of the war.
It has a funny effect
on both sides.
It does something to Robert.
It does something
to the locals.
And that's not even America,
Paris really doesn't have any
kind of special connotation I
don't think to the locals in
the sense that Robert
is not really never
considered a Frenchman.
But when it comes to invocation
of the United
States, it's a different
story.
They all know that that's
something that he has a
relation to.
And in the progression, we're
starting out with the most
benign, at least not completely
not innocuous
invocation of the
United States.
And this is Missoula, Montana,
where Robert Jordan is from,
and where he's thinking that he
will go back to after war
and that maybe he'll take
Maria with him.
And this is actually a good
moment to think about exactly
the nature of that
romance between
Robert Jordan and Maria.
"Why not marry her?
Sure, he thought.
I will marry her.
Then we'll be Mr. and
Mrs. Robert Jordan
of Sun Valley, Idaho.
Or Corpus Christi, Texas,
or Butte, Montana.
Spanish girls make
wonderful wives.
I've never had one so I know.
And when I get my job back at
the university she can be an
instructor's wife and when
undergraduates who take
Spanish IV come in to smoke
pipes in the evening and have
those so valuable informal
discussions about Quevedo,
Lope de Vega, Galdos and the
other always admirable dead,
Maria can tell them about how
some of the blue-shirted
crusaders for the true faith sat
on her head while others
twisted her arms and pulled her
skirts up and stuffed them
in her mouth."
I began by saying that this is
relatively benign, but in fact
there's no such thing as the
benign invocation of the
distant home in Hemingway.
Even from beginning to end,
there's something very funny
about the tone of
that invocation.
The first part of it is--
the first little bit of it about
going back to all the
cities that were kind of the
heartland of America, and then
the particular job
that he had.
He was a professor at the
university teaching Spanish.
And kind of the joke about
people coming in, informal
discussions, I would say that
actually is kind of a benign
irony in the sense that we all
tend to be ironic about things
actually that we are
quite attached to.
I noticed yesterday.
I was talking about a writer
that I love who
writes about food.
And I said, she's cornered--
she has two books out on
food-- and I said she's
cornered the
market on food writing.
And the person who
I was talking to
really looked at me.
But I actually love
this author.
But that's just my way of not
being too attached, showing
some critical distance.
So the first part of that is
just the kinds of the typical
professional irony towards
something that you really
actually do want to go back to
and have some yearning for.
But in the midst of that, Robert
just can't stop himself
from importing something else
to that otherwise benign
environment.
And so we sort of know
ahead of time that
Maria was once raped.
We have no idea when
that happened.
This is Hemingway's way of
telling the story, giving bits
and pieces of the story
one at a time.
So this particular importation
of something that happens in
Spain into an otherwise innocent
American environment
has the weight not only of
darkening the textures of that
otherwise innocent college
town, but also completely
changes his relation to
the local setting.
It's not even just a place
where he's having
trouble with Pablo.
That's the least
of the problem.
They're much more deeply
rooted problems.
So this is another spin
on the idea of being
rooted in your community.
Usually when we think of being
rooted in our community, we
just think of having stayed
there for a long time, maybe
having been there for
generations or at least within
the life of a person,
many, many years.
And usually it's a good thing.
But there's another way in which
being rooted in your
environment means that all the
dark episodes from the past
are visited upon you, or all the
feuds, or the old angers,
old hatreds, are constantly
being reactivated.
Sometimes just in memory, and
sometimes reenacted in the
bodies of people who are
otherwise young.
Maria is a very young girl.
But what is being visited upon
her is not personal.
It really has nothing
to do with her.
They don't mean to rape Maria.
They make raping her as a symbol
of something else.
So this is the other-- this is
the hazard of spending all
your life and being rooted in
one particular community.
It's that ancient angers can be
inherited by people who are
relatively young.
So I would say this is the basic
dynamics of the relation
between the United
States and Spain.
It's that there's a kind of a
spill over in both directions,
something very violent spilling
over into the
American context.
And then we'll see another way
in which the violence of the
American context will spill over
into the Spanish setting.
And this is still a relatively
benign instance.
But again something just
not quite right.
"Yes"--
and talking about gypsies.
And I should say that Hemingway
actually is
surprisingly far-sighted about
the problem of the gypsies.
They're now called Roma, and
it's a huge problem in the
sense that the European Union
is recognizing the fact that
the Romas actually have always
been oppressed by various
national governments.
So it's quite a big
issue in Europe.
And Hemingway back when he was
writing about Spanish Civil
War already seemed to
have caught on.
"'Yes,' Anselmo said.
'The gypsies believe the bear
to be a brother of man.' 'So
also believe the Indians in
America,' Robert Jordan said.
'And when they kill a bear, they
apologize to him and ask
his pardon...' 'Do you have
any gypsy blood?' 'No.
But I have seen much of them
and clearly, since the
movement, more.
There are many in the hills.
To them it is not a sin to
kill outside the tribe.
They deny this but it is true.'
'Like the Moors.'"
So it is not a sin to kill
outside a tribe.
Usually, I mean for most of us,
the injunction is against
killing, period.
So there's just no qualifying
after that.
But according to Anselmo, it
is completely OK for the
gypsies to kill anyone outside
of the immediate tribe.
So it's a straight
ethnic divide.
Within your own tribe, you
don't kill anyone, or you
don't kill anyone unless
you're under serious
provocation.
Outside of your tribe, you're
free to kill anyone.
So that's a incredible charge to
level against the gypsies.
But what is weird is that
Robert then comes
up with this analogy.
It's that the gypsies are
just like the Moors.
So this might not make any
sense to us right now.
But it turns out that this is
actually one of the aspects of
the deep cultural
roots in Spain.
This is a beautiful instance
of the Moorish
architecture in Spain.
You guys know that the Moors
from Africa, from North
Africa, actually were the rulers
in Spain for 800 years.
It was in 1492, the same year
that Columbus discovered the
New World, it was the same
year that the Moors were
expelled from Spain
along with Jews.
The Moors and the Jews were
the two persecuted ethnic
groups in Spain.
And so when Isabella of Castile
expelled the Moors
from Grenada, there was this
policy throughout Spain to try
to erase Islamic
book learning.
Cordoba was a huge center
of learning
throughout the Middle Ages.
And people from all over Europe
would go to Cordoba to
study, Arabic science was
very, very advanced.
Arabic Moorish architecture
was beautiful.
Cordoba had bath houses, more
public baths than any other
city in Europe.
It was basically a beacon
of enlightenment in
Spain, in all of Europe.
And when they were destroyed by
the Catholic forces, by the
Catholic monarchs, there was
much of an attempt to try to
erase all of that.
It wasn't successful.
So we still today, if we were to
go to Cordoba or Toledo, we
would still see lots of
Moorish architecture.
So there's one kind of sore
point in Spanish history.
It's that they really have done
this to a very glorious
civilization.
But there's another sore point
that is more immediate to the
Spanish Civil War.
And this is reported by the
American poet Langston Hughes
who was there along
with Hemingway.
And Langston Hughes was really
struck by the presence of the
Moors in the Spanish
Civil War.
So he wrote several pieces
about the Moors, after
sometimes seeing them in the
hospitals and actually having
this very uneasy kinship between
himself and the Moors.
So this is from his essay
General Franco's Moors.
"The Moorish troops were
colonial conscripts, or men
from the Moroccan villages
enticed into the army by
offers of what seemed to
them very good pay.
Franco's personal body guard
consisted of Moorish soldiers,
tall picturesque fellows
in flowing
robes and winding turbans.
Before I left home, American
papers that carried
photographs of turbaned,
Mohammadan troops marching in
the streets of Burgos,
Seville, and Malaga.
And the United Press dispatch
from Gibraltar that summer
said "Arabs had been crossing
the Straits of Gibraltar from
Spanish Morocco to Algeciras and
Malaga at the rate of 300
to 400 a day...
General Franco intends to mass
50,000 new Arab troops in
Spain."
So given the past history,
given the uneasy relation
between the Spanish and Moorish
population of North
Africa, for General Franco
actually to use the Moorish
troops as very active combat
units against the Spanish
Republican side, that is about
the worst he could have done.
It was successful actually.
He won the war.
But it was about the worst in
terms of being tone-deaf.
He was probably about as
tone-deaf as anyone could be
who won at the end.
But that's what happened.
And so there were indeed lots
and lots of pictures of the
Moors crossing over from Africa
just paid to fight the
Spanish Republic.
Here are his Moorish body
guards, and they're engaged in
more active combat.
So to bring up the Moors, I
don't even know what motivates
Robert to make that analogy
between the
gypsies and the Moors.
It couldn't really be just
blindness or just callousness.
I think there's some
intentionality in there.
But it's sort of hard to know
why he would want to bring up
this very, very sensitive
issue for the Spanish.
So I think that all we can say
is that it seems that it's
very easy for an involuntary
foreigner to say something
that is wounding to the
locals, maybe without
intending it to have the extent
of the insult, the
extent of the injury that is
actually the actual outcome of
saying something like that.
Robert probably had no idea
that mentioning the Moors
would create those kinds of
connotations, those kind of
just edginess on the part of
the Spanish here is, but
that's what he's doing.
So once again, the kind of a
spilling over, thinking about
Native Americans with their own
very uneasy history in the
United States.
Think about Native Americans,
thinking about gypsies in
Europe, and thinking
about the Moors.
Three ethnic groups all with
uneasy histories behind them.
And it is the invocation of all
three of them in the same
breath that makes that
particular exchange especially
uncomfortable, if not
downright hurtful.
But let's just look at a more
serious instance of this kind
of distant home being a kind of
irritation to the immediate
environment.
So all of a sudden out of
nowhere, Robert Jordan
suddenly starts talking about
lynching in Ohio.
This is completely
uncalled for.
This is in the context of
talking about the execution of
the fascists.
And out of the blue, Robert just
mentions this lynching
that he was a witness to,
and about the effect of
drunkenness on people
in general.
"'It is so,' Robert
Jordan said.
'When I was seven years old and
going with my mother to
attend a wedding in the state
of Ohio at which I was to be
the boy of a pair of boy and
girl who carry flowers.' 'Did
you do that?' Said Maria.
'How nice.' 'In this town a
Negro was hanged to a lamp
post and later burned.
It was an arc light.
A light which lowered from
the post to the pavement.
And he was hoisted, first by the
mechanism which was used
to hoist the arc light
but this broke.'
This is a bizarre description of
lynching to say the least.
It's stuck in the middle of
this long story about
execution of the fascists.
And not only that, but it seems
that much of the focus
is on the mechanism of hoisting
this person up who's
about to be lynched, and
on how unreliable
this mechanism is.
It breaks once and then he has
to be done over again.
So what we can say is that
there's a slightly out of
focus nature to the invocation
of the United States.
The proper focus really
ought to be on the
act of lynching itself.
Anyone telling the story--
it would have been on
the act of lynching.
And instead, it is out of focus
so that it somehow is
just focused on the mechanism
of hoisting the person up.
And I think as a kind of
deliberate blurriness that
suggests that this is really how
the United States looks to
the Spanish locals, that they
can't get the focus right.
It's somehow off.
And that off focus is dramatized
by Maria's response
which is completely
inappropriate, shows the
highest degree of ignorance.
Well, she doesn't know
what's coming.
But just to say "how nice."
She has no idea.
She's completely out of it.
She doesn't get any of it.
So the reference to the lynching
might seem out of the
blue to us reading For Whom
the Bell Tolls right now.
But lynching actually
was a big issue
all through the 1930s.
Even though the actual number
of lynching had declined at
that point.
It was highlighted, it was
brought to the public
consciousness for a
number of reasons.
One is this very famous song
that I think that you guys
probably have heard, Billie
Holiday's Strange Fruit, 1939.
It's a great collaboration
between a black singer and
actually the songwriter was
Jewish, Abel Meeropol.
So this is one of the first
instances of a black-Jewish
collaboration resulting in this
classic song in the jazz
repertoire.
But these are the lyrics
of Strange Fruit.
And you can see why that image
would lead to those lyrics.
"Southern trees bear
a strange fruit.
Blood on the leaves,
blood at the root.
Black bodies swinging in
the Southern breeze.
Strange fruit hanging from
the tops of the trees.
Pastoral scene of the gallant
South, the bulging eyes and
the twisted mouth.
The scent of magnolia,
sweet and fresh.
Then the sudden smell
of burning flesh.
Here is a fruit for the crows
to pluck, for the rain to
gather, for the wind to suck.
For the sun to rot, for
the trees to drop.
Here is a strange and
bitter crop."
The lyrics--
and Billie Holiday is the one
who made the song famous, but
really it was Abel Meeropol
that made the song such a
great song.
And I think the power of the
song really just comes from
the contrast, the alternate
rhythm, between the kind of
cliche image of the South, you
know the pastoral South, the
magnolia, the smell of magnolia,
and then the smell
of the burning flesh.
It's that alternate rhythm that
generates the peculiar
power of this song.
So that's partly why lynching
was such an issue on
everyone's consciousness
in the '30s.
But there were also
other issues.
And in fact, the song is a
great song, but it's also
slightly misleading in a sense
that it's suggesting that
lynching was strictly a Southern
phenomenon, which
actually wasn't the case.
And so all we have to do is to
look at this New Yorker cover
on March 19, 1938.
Very late, really very, very
late for this to be on the New
Yorker's cover, this racist--
just the Northern population
being flabbergasted at how
lazy and drunken blacks are,
because they were migrating in
large numbers to the North.
So a relatively new phenomenon
in the twentieth century
actually was the substantial
number of lynchings both in
the Northeast and also in the
Midwest. So this is a kind of
very famous double lynching of
Thomas Shipp and Abram Smith
in Indiana in 1930.
So once again, very,
very late for that.
And it's because of these very
sensational lynchings in the
North that the NAACP actually
had this regular practice of
just hanging out a flag in
the New York City office
announcing that a man was
lynched yesterday.
And that was also
in the 1930s.
So it was something that was
an ongoing problem and very
much kind of a hot button
issue in the 1930s.
So as a consequence of that,
there was an anti-lynching
bill that was trying to make its
way through Congress and
the Senate.
And it passed in the House, but
because of a filibuster in
the Senate, it led to the
withdrawal of the bill in
February of 1938.
So it was just something that
just never went away.
It was an unresolved issue all
the way through the 1930s.
And so Hemingway actually was
very much plugged into the
politics of the United States
when all of a sudden he would
make Robert Jordan suddenly make
a reference to lynching.
But just to move away from that
history of lynching in
the United States, back to
its impact on the Spanish
environment.
The response of Maria and
Pilar to lynching in the
United States is once
again very odd.
"'As I said, when they lifted
the Negro up for the second
time, my mother pulled me away
from the window, so I saw no
more,' Robert Jordan said.
'But since I have had
experiences which demonstrate
that drunkenness is the same
in my country.
It is ugly and brutal.' 'You
were too young at seven,'
Maria said. 'You were too
young for such things.
I have never seen a Negro
except in a circus.
Unless the Moors are Negroes.'
'Some are Negroes and some are
not," Pilar said. 'I can talk
to you of the Moors.'"
So this is mind-boggling, that
this should be the response to
lynching in the United States.
We can't even say that-- it
would be reassuring to say
that it's just cultural
ignorance or the impossibility
of cross-cultural understanding
that is
resulting in the responses
from Maria and Pilar.
It would be nice to be able just
to say, it's because they
don't know anything about
the United States.
But I really don't think
that that is the case.
So I would invite you, actually,
this is something to
think about.
Why do Spanish always
have such weird --
and that's putting it mildly --
weird responses to violence
in the United States, period?
The response is never
the right response.
It's always so off-focus
that it's not
even the wrong response.
It's just hard to believe
that anyone would
respond like that.
But what we see right there is
that this once again weird
invocation of the Moors in
conjunction with violence in
the United States.
So all we know is that when
they try to make sense of
something they don't understand,
when the Spanish
try to make sense of something
they don't understand, the
Moors are the people who
come to their minds.
But it's a moment where any
kind of communion between
Robert and Maria and Pilar, any
previous communion between
them is completely
breaking down.
So I just wanted to talk about
another episode that has
exactly the same kind
of construction of
incomprehension, ignorance,
and incomprehension on the
part of the Spanish.
And this has to do with
the Republican party.
You guys remember that the
leftists in Spain were the
Republicans.
They are defending the
Spanish Republic.
So to be a Republican
in Spain means that
you are on the left.
And this is the context
for that conversation.
"'My father was a Republican
all his life,' Maria said.
'It was for that that they shot
him.' 'My father was also
a Republican all his life.
Also my grandfather,' Robert
Jordan said. 'In what
country?' 'The United States.'
'Did they shoot them?' the
woman asked.
'Que va,' Maria said.
'The United States is a country
of Republicans.
They don't shoot you for being
a Republican there.' 'All the
same, it is a good thing to have
a grandfather who was a
Republican,' the woman said. 'It
shows a good blood.' 'My
grandfather was on the
Republican national
committee,' Robert
Jordan said.
That impressed even Maria.
'And is thy father still
active in the
Republic?' Pilar asked.
'No.
He is dead.' 'Can one ask how
he died?' 'He shot himself.'
'For avoiding being tortured?'
The woman asked.
'Yes,' Robert Jordan said.
'To avoid being tortured.'"
So this is where we get
that mix of the
comic and the tragic.
It is a comedy of
errors so far.
For a good part of that passage,
it is a comedy of
cross-cultural error.
Just not being able to wrap your
mind around the fact that
to be a Republican in the
United States is a very
different thing than being
a Republican in Spain.
So just not being able to--
this is just kind of permanent
blinders in the minds
of Maria and Pilar.
So if that were just the case,
it would go no further.
That would just be a moment of
comic relief in For Whom the
Bell Tolls.
But as is always the case with
Hemingway in this particular
novel, the comic suddenly morphs
into something else
without any warning.
So all of a sudden we get the
detail about Robert Jordan's
father shooting himself to
avoid being tortured.
And that can have only one
meaning for the Spanish.
It fits completely into the
personal history of Maria.
It fits completely into Pilar's
understanding of
political history in Spain.
But right now we don't know why
his father killed himself
and what kind of torture
he is talking about.
So we have to wait a little
longer to have that mystery
cleared up for us.
And to have that mystery cleared
up, we actually have
to go further into the past.
So I've been talking about
distant homes in times just
of spatial locations.
But there's also a distant
temporal home.
In turns out that the nineteenth
century is also a
necessary home for
Robert Jordan,
especially the Civil War.
It's almost the equivalent
of Paris in terms of
psychological need
for that home.
And it's not just any
Civil War, but his
grandfather's Civil War.
And this is his moment
of homecoming.
This is the home that will
receive him and shelter him.
"Remember something concrete
and practical.
Remember Grandfather's saber,
bright and well oiled in its
dented scabbard and Grandfather
showed you how the
blade had been thinned from the
many times it had been to
the grinder's.
Remember Grandfather's
Smith and Wesson.
It was a single action,
officer's model .32 caliber
and there was no
trigger guard.
It had the softest, sweetest
trigger pull you had ever felt
and it was always well oiled
and the bore was clean
although the finish was all worn
off and the brown metal
of the barrel and the cylinder
was worn smooth from the
leather of the holster."
So this is, like Hemingway's
description of the trout
fishing in In Our Time.
Very, very clean,
the smoothness,
cleanness of their operation.
But in this particular context
the smoothness and the
cleanness and the worn-out-ness
of that pistol
suggests that this is
a well-used weapon.
Robert Johnson's grandfather was
a hero of the Civil War.
His saber had been to the
grinder's numerous times
because the blade had
been so well used.
So without saying anything,
without using the word "glory"
or "heroic" or any comparable
adjective, Hemingway gives us
the sense that the Civil War was
the heroic moment, was the
high point, in the history
of Robert's family.
And it was very much vested
in his grandfather.
And at that point,
it has receded.
It has to recede, it has to be
receded into the past. It
belongs to the nineteenth
century.
But Robert Jordan wants to
activate it over and over
again, bring it up to the
twentieth century because he
needs that.
And we know why he needs to
bring the nineteenth century
back on the next page
when we know what
happens to that pistol.
"Then after you father had shot
himself with the pistol,
and you had come home from
school and they'd had the
funeral, the coroner had
returned it after the inquest
saying, "Bob, I guess you might
want to keep the gun."
OK, I should just stop and
clarify that this is something
we'll be talking about,
actually the narrative
switches from second person
pronoun, Robert Jordan
addressing himself as you.
So that you is Robert Jordan,
and then it switches back to
the third person.
"He climbed out on a rock and
leaned over and saw his face
in the still water, and saw
himself holding the gun, and
then he dropped it, holding it
by the muzzle and saw it go
down making bubbles until it
was just as big as a watch
charm in the clear water and
then it was out of sight." So
this passage that comes just on
the opposite page from the
previous invocation of the
Civil War weapons of the
grandfather tell us exactly why
the nineteenth century and
the Civil War is a necessary
emotional shelter for Robert.
He's just so ashamed
of his father.
He wants to clean up that entire
episode, drop it into
the clear water so
that it will be
completely out of sight.
He can do that to the pistol.
He can't do it to the actual
history itself, but that's as
close as he can get to wiping
out that history.
And so in this moment actually,
there is no Spanish
environment that is invoked.
This is no mention of the
immediate Spanish setting.
And I think that that is
suggestive as well, in a sense
that really the home is for
Robert, I think, and it's a
very pessimistic reading
of the novel.
There are basically just
two homes for Robert.
One is the Paris of the
evening papers and the
chestnut trees.
And the other home for him is
a home that never was a home
that was in his lifetime, but
a home that he can inherit
vicariously through
his grandfather.
And that is the American Civil
War as his spiritual home.
Because this is the one place
where he has affirmation of
himself, that he's not ashamed
of himself, not ashamed of his
family history.
And so those are impossible
homes for him at this point.